[Music]
[Applause]
ryan clark will uh be on site for espn
super bowl coverage we always uh are
smarter after we talk to ryan you can uh
see him on a lot of the mothership shows
and uh he also is the host of face first
podcast and ryan joining us on the
program right good to have you back um
let's go back to the bills and the
chiefs and let's fix overtime in the
postseason or do we need to fix overtime
in the postseason
you know i think it's uh it's one of
those things where
obviously people are upset that a guy
like josh allen after playing one of the
best games we've ever seen in the
playoffs from a quarterback doesn't get
an opportunity to score right it doesn't
get an opportunity uh to have his
rebuttal uh per se against what patrick
mahomes did and so i get that
for me the hard thing is is when you
talk about player safety and some of
these rules that we've set in place we
can't have alabama auburn you know from
this from the 2021 season with patrick
mahomes and josh allen you can't have it
go
through the 25-yard line possessions and
then to the two-point conversions it
didn't say in the same breath that
player safety is important but i do
think it's important that the best team
wins and you have 60 minutes to do that
and if you're the buffalo bills you also
had 13 seconds to do it right you had an
opportunity to keep them from getting in
field goal range and allowing harrison
bucker uh to tie the game up um and
you're the number one defense in the
world uh dp and you can't and you can't
stop him from scoring a touchdown in the
first overtime drive but um i think we
also know that if the buffalo bills get
the ball first with the way they were
playing patrick mahomes wouldn't have
got an opportunity either and so
as the week has gone on i've grown
closer and closer to saying that maybe
we should fix the overtime rules um
in
in in the playoffs but it'd have to be a
smart way to do it and i'm not
necessarily sure i have that solution
see i just think it's
chiefs get a chance
uh if and if they score
then the bills know they're going to get
a chance and then after
then after that it's sudden death
overtime
both teams got their chance and you know
whatever happens after that and i know
that we want to factor in well the bills
should have won this game they should
have squibbed the kick they i mean come
on 13 seconds and you're gonna let
mahomes do that to you
but i think if you want to be fair
then that would probably be the fair and
equitable way to do it then we would
have gotten josh allen in his chance and
really this is about the nfl being in
the business of entertainment
what would have been more entertaining
then josh allen now comes back out with
the season on the line this is the duel
that you won and i think that that's it
would set up
here's the the other part of it is the
other part of it is to
to to see patrick mahomes complete the
football to travis kelsey take off the
helmet run down like that that's
exciting as well it's exciting to know
that from that position on the field
that the buffalo bills don't come up
with a stop then
their season is over and so i think that
the the excitement part
doesn't doesn't waver or doesn't wane
with the way that everything's set up
now but i do believe that the fairness
side of it is different right if we're
going to just talk about you know
fairness and in the other sense of it
if the kansas city chiefs get the ball
first and they score and then josh allen
comes down and he scores and then kansas
city gets it back because they got they
won the toss and they score again we're
going to have the same conversation
well josh allen didn't get two chances
and patrick
no no no because then it would be on
your defense i would say no you had your
chance they had their chance and and
that's it i was also wondering i think
we had you on earlier in the season we
were talking about what defenses were
doing to kansas city and you know we
were saying all right patrick mahomes
now has to be a little bit more
economical going down the field
doesn't seem like he's as economical as
he was during the season when we weren't
sure about that chief's offense or
suddenly nfl defenses had a solution
i think he's i think he's more
economical now
which
has lended to some big plays with yards
after the catch this isn't the patrick
mahomes that threw for 50 touchdowns and
everything was about stretching the
field vertically um you look to the
tyree kill play against two men when he
beats levi wallace that's an
intermediate throw that the fastest man
in football takes and makes it a 65-yard
uh touchdown but that what i've seen
from patrick mahomes is more patience
i've seen patrick mahomes make better
decisions within the pocket and without
and outside of the pocket um this has
been a strange evolution of patrick
mahomes he's always going to be
extremely talented and extremely
explosive but i've seen him check the
football down i've seen him from the
pocket understand travis kelsey is the
first read i have to hit him in the zone
we've also watched his mechanics get
better as the season's gone along i am
as impressed
with who he started as what it was in
the middle of the season and who he is
now as i've ever been impressed with any
players evolution in one year and i
think it really points to his greatness
and there was a moment though ryan where
you you see mahomes at the line of
scrimmage
changing the play for kelsey and he
yells out to kels do it so you do it
kels okay if i'm on buffalo
[Laughter]
w yeah exactly
like i i'm i'm guessing travis kelsey is
the kels he's talking about and if
you're a buffalo like how the hell does
he catch a pass
well you know what they they turned it
into playground football though dp like
so i always had a problem playing mag
right and here's why i couldn't play
maddie madden because it wasn't a real
game
you know if if i'm doubling heinz ward
and i'm playing my 10 year old son at
the time and he keeps throwing the ball
to heinz ward and screaming at me
you can't stop heinz but i know i'm
doubling i'm pissed off because i'm like
that's not real football
what travis kelsey and patrick mahomes
did was not real football he said travis
kelsey says in the post game presser i
told him i'm not going to run a play i'm
just going to run to where it's open
and patrick mahomes to him two of the
greatest players in the world go do it
kels do it
and if you watch patrick mahomes he
pumps the ball twice because he don't
know where the hell is
[Laughter]
i know it's who would you rather face
mahomes or josh allen
wow that's like saying what would you
rather do die burning or drowning um
can i go with neither
can i pick jimmy garoppolo
[Laughter]
you know i think i think uh i'll pick
patrick mahomes because i think he's the
better player
um but what josh allen presents from a
physical standpoint right now in the
league is unmatched it's if
it's if prime cam newton was a better
passer yeah and a more explosive passer
yeah that's that's that's a great
analogy and i i don't like my
quarterbacks running
but it feels like he has to run and i
and i thought if they were going to win
in the playoffs he needed to have that
element of danger there
in the minds and they were going to go
for it on fourth downs so you just no
we're it's full speed ahead like we're
not stopping this is the only way we're
gonna win is not kicking field goals and
i i i was really amazed that
josh allen and i was critical of him
when he first came in uh okay i just
didn't think that he
he he knew the game i i thought he like
he panicked and i mean he's matured so
much
that you go toe-to-toe and i never
thought that i'd be seeing josh allen go
toe-to-toe with patrick mahomes you know
i i said it in the off season when i
picked
buffalo kansas city in the afc
championship that i felt like josh allen
showed us throughout last year he could
stand across from from patrick mahomes
on the other sideline and feel just as
confident confident in his abilities as
patrick mahomes could there were times
this year i disagreed with that and then
about the second half of the tampa bay
buccaneer game he started to use his
legs again and his athleticism and his
physicality and it's so crazy sometimes
uh a coach can look at his team and say
you know what here is what we need to do
josh allen actually showed offensive
coordinator brian dayball what to do
because that team wasn't running the
football before that and when josh
started to run it now singletary got
involved and the quarterback runs got
involved if we go back to the the ice
bowl or the wind bowled winbow against
the patriots josh allen should have run
the ball four to five times in the red
zone and they went
they changed that after that game and
now you saw the team that we got to see
this weekend against kansas city chiefs
he's ryan clark espn nfl analyst uh you
mentioned jimmy garoppolo what's his
reputation
you know um
i mean his reputation for dating is that
is definitely uh something
that we uh that we point to as we like
more than his football play
um i think jimmy garoppolo's reputation
is one of he'll try to give a game away
right we you know we talk about it all
the time that you know the interception
in the red zone interception against
dallas we feel like there are games
where jimmy garoppolo puts his team in
danger of losing
and on the other side of it
wins all the time
he is the biggest oxymoron
or the biggest you know ends of the
spectrum as a quarterback that they have
on any successful team if you look at
who the san francisco 49ers are from a
win-loss perspective with jimmy
garoppolo and without it's night and day
but do you believe this though
that you here's the saying you can lose
with me but you can't win without me
yeah i've never heard that saying i feel
like that's some mythical thing you just
made up no jury
terry bradshaw said this
years ago and it felt like it's
applicable to jimmy g that you know hey
i can mess up and we can lose but you do
need me
you know for for us to win but i i mean
i don't know if that's true or not but
it just feels everybody goes jimmy g he
just wins and i go yeah i think no i
think that's
for for what they've been since he'd
been there no if you get aaron rodgers
would i take aaron rodgers yes or tom
brady yes or any of those great
quarterbacks but for who he's been as a
san francisco 49ers that's the perfect
49er that's the perfect um
i would say analogy or the perfect
saying for who jimmy g is yeah
explain to me from a defensive backs
perspective
cooper cup
you know and
i can say this on your show
if cooper cup were black we'd all talk
about him in a different way
um
in the sense that a lot of times
we we look at the color of a wide
receiver and we want to compare them to
people who they look like more so than
people who they play like
right cooper cup is gonna you know
cooper cup is not julie and edelman
cooper cup is not wes west walker right
cooper cup is in the conversation with
the devonta adams and with the deandre
hopkins of the world cup is a man that
can play every single position he's an
excellent route runner but if you listen
to him talk about the game right and
explain why he does certain things why
they run certain routes he speaks about
the game like a quarterback and so i
think and so to me
cooper cup is is a devante adams uh
justin jefferson he he's in the the the
conversations with those type of guys
for feel of the game
route running and catching ability
i'll give you the comp i have for cooper
cup
he doesn't play any longer he's going to
the hall of fame
okay
and he
works with tom brady occasionally
he works with tom brady occasionally
larry antonio brown larry fitzgerald
antonio brown
all right all right i don't think cooper
cup would ever be compared to antonio
brown i i see uh cooper cup and larry
fitzgerald
yeah i think i think i think the i think
larry was was bigger
and honestly never as good of a route
runner just to be to be truthful with
you i think cooper cup is
uh
is as as route running goes i think he's
one of the greatest that's ever lived
really this is
i do from you go back to the not the
catch on the big catch on antoine
winfield but the catch before where
they're in two man on murphy uh on
murphy bunting right he gets to the top
of that route and murphy bunting
understands that he has to be inside
cooper cup right at the top of it his
drought sticks him inside and makes him
fall
right that's some let's for a basketball
comp that's some alec iverson steph
curry cp3 type movement you know and to
me like larry never had that larry was
was bigger and larry had great hands
cooper creates so much separation with
his route running man that i just think
it's so underrated the the type of
athlete and player that he is it's
always great to talk to you ryan thanks
for joining us we appreciate it and uh
have fun
all right well man have a great day all
right that's ryan clark
i told you i always look forward to
having him on